[Applause]
do you have a note emily shocker shocker
emily's got a problem with my appearance
it's just that there's a white thing in
your eyebrow and what is it i don't know
it's you're jealous of my looks like a
booger i got laid and you didn't and
you're telling me i got laid on saturday
first time in two years so come at me
well i think he already did
it was in his parents house right
[Laughter]
emily is a new woman i don't know what
is going on
but
she's getting laid she's wearing lip
liner she's going to concert goes to a
concert once emily recently discovered
concerts and
she was she texted me on her whatever i
was facetiming you from where the fuck i
was
um
anytime i'm doing a a show uh a comedy
yuck show on the road
usually by the time i get back to the
hotel uh
the weirdest person i've ever seen runs
up to me and it's like
no they're not weird they're just very
like
like intense and like i'm like
someone will walk up to me i'm like this
person's friends with this boy like
they'll be wearing like a charcoal gray
turtleneck and like
like wedge boots my brain is like this
person is coming from just like like
americans human resource office to serve
me papers that's the energy they're
coming at me with the way they walk up
to me is never like hi um i was like hi
i'm friends with emily like
like and i have to drop everything i'm
doing just like okay what are we
and then i met your friends and then
they made me watch
sleight of hand magic that like in the
lobby and i was which was it was it was
very fun but i was like you clearly know
nothing about me
i was upset about that it was really fun
actually i text idea i dm because i
don't have her number but i dm'd her and
i was like get that magician away from
whitney it's the oh like truly the only
thing that scares me is magic but the
guy did do actually a very cool trick
which i will uh play which made like a
ring disappear like i was wearing my my
wild horse stone
robbed you and yeah
yeah it's still
gone and my wallet he made all it
disappeared and then uh uh it would go
off one finger and off another finger
and i was like
like
having a woman
like he would put it on different
fingers and you're just like what
happening i'm like a 39 year old woman
like moving a ring around to a ring
finger by ac like it's a very risky
thing to be doing taking off it rings
and putting them on like but um
okay so emily uh is a new woman
last night we went to the foo fighters
studio 666 from yeah which whitney is
this star female that's very funny
that's very nice which is so good um
okay so this is okay so something's
happening my hair is now brown and you
look 15. people what does that mean it
means for some reason
like colorful hair made you you look
younger with your god-given hair keep
going keep going just waiting for you to
step and shit right now
i'm complimenting you it's like me doing
the the uh clothing intervention earlier
today
i can't watch emily wear these ratty
t-shirts because you're like carolyn
beside kenny we got it and you'll wear
like your nicest white t-shirt and it's
you know when you like worn it oh the
pit stains no it's not even yes there's
a little yellow but they're just like
it's too tight around the shoulders
because i have fake boobs we know we all
know yeah do not have fake boobs okay i
do know i really don't you don't have to
lie everywhere you don't think i would
have asked them to fix my inverted
nipple if i had real if i'd gotten them
done you think i'd be like no leave that
one headlight
please doctor
i didn't say you went to a doctor
i thought you were disappointed
some room with the beach like kiosk
oh god
um okay so
i uh all of you are on notice everyone i
work with
because whatever that means
i know what that means i guess that
means i'm going to text you back at some
point
you're going to take our notifications
off silent
that's a new thing for the app i mean
the the download the update
the down date
emily went on a date
um no i didn't
he didn't take me on a date
he just took me to pound
oh my god
i okay there's a couple things that
actually make me cringe and
that is one of them what do not say that
i have a pt yes i don't i'm not okay
with that
axe wound i will not i'm not okay with
axe you know what guys say like oh my
god
i know that should be illegal and uh
strange i do not approve of strange when
someone guys are to go get some strange
what does that mean it means i'm going
to go like have sex with some random
girl like the guy that
you on saturday you were straight that's
not true he's a friend of a he's a
brother of a friend so he's a
interesting he's a brother
he's my cousin
it's not strange at all it's not strange
it's incest
i'm gonna go get some incest
the way you fucking we are a little
hungover
pound down isn't
i don't think people really say that
anymore right pat just the kind of
people i hang out with that's a dad of
two
they're still saying it they're still
saying it they're still saying it yeah
yeah he's in the chat room he's on
reddit he's working he's gonna he's
gonna be up on the the kids lingo uh i
don't i don't love the word panties oh
who likes that no one do you like
railing bail
no okay just checking
well i don't know what kind of sex are
people have because it makes me just
wonder what kind of sex people are
having like i don't
i lay down my legs are together like
there's a hole in the sheets yeah
there's not a lot of like i mean maybe
back in the day but like there's there's
not like a pounding like these words
like are like i murdered it like i pound
i railed it like what do you mean yeah
no you're right i just think about you
know when you like uh go downstairs
there's a railing you like jump on it
and
isn't that kind of like the slide down
everything because then the first thing
i think of rail i think train i'm like
you ran a train oh i'm i'm too literal
for these expressions i uh yeah no i
have sex once every two to three years
and then i go back underground so um
i'll see what happens in two years what
we're saying okay after the concert
uh emily and i uh well we first of all
went to the food fighters concert it's
look i don't get to go to concerts very
often i don't get to shows we don't get
to go see magical things like we work at
night you know like i have to be the
magical thing people come see
and he's the concert i don't get to see
a bunch of like shows no my shows are
way louder than the food betters
just me alone um and uh so it's like
you you look at jaded you just go like
oh i don't get to enjoy things like yeah
yeah you know and or you're like i have
to film this to post it or it's like a
band you don't like very much it was
like to be at the foo fighter show which
like yeah we know dave he's been on the
podcast he's so great and so cool you
forget he's like a famous rock star it
was pretty awesome it was insane it was
awesome
i mean it was
i was pinching myself um okay keep
talking taylor hawkins sang a queen song
and dave got on the drums
that was that's what you say that's not
something you see every day no do you
know how lucky we were to see that we're
gonna post it for you guys so that you
can see it too i filmed the whole thing
and put it on my instagram because i was
like we need to share this moment it's
but she doesn't archive things she you
guys have 24 hours to see it if you
don't put it on the main feed oh good i
didn't know you know how to do that i'm
going to play a video of emily at the
foo fighters concert because every uh
having the best night every couple
weeks
i see a part of emily i just
like what is happening that was a white
wine spritzer
20 minutes later she was on all fours
licking it off the ground so i did not
get that shot unfortunately but no one
has more fun than you i know you know
why because here's the thing i feel like
i'm fun but i don't like when people are
fun but not together you can't leave
your purse you can't lose your shoes i
can't i might lose your shoes
what if someone takes them and throws
them into a parking garage the best
thing you can do as a friend
is release them
from the shoes they cannot
like throw away
they it's probably gonna be um a forever
21 maybe a zara
every now that's an aldo
or a nine west when you see a nine west
just instantly just because this is
something that you know we get emotional
attachments to things that hurt us
sometimes and you you might have
stockholm syndrome with um with the
kitten heel or uh espadrille an
espadrille and emily had a a steve
madden which isn't he in jail like like
after imprisoning your feet for 30 years
he has gone to prison no oh no the guy
from american apparel too a lot of these
people went to jail everyone in the mall
yeah everyone
spencer
sam goody
auntie anne
mrs fields
no never which by the way i think we
might have martha stewart on the show
soon what i know not that sorry i'm
sorry martha mrs field i went from mrs
fields to martha stewart well she's not
coming down because i was like who would
play mrs fields in like a mrs fields
movie because you know the cookie
monster i just auditioned to play
marjory post for the seinfeld movie so
now i'm like obsessed with like
just these like random people in history
that are these brands that we see
everywhere yeah and they're like oh
that's like a human being right right i
don't know that's kind of cool to me
like playing real life people which in
the foo fighters movie i actually play
this kind of um i have to stop saying
this about because i was doing press
about i was going to play this like
crazy encino whore like groupie that
just wants to sleep with everyone and
then when i was uh we were upstairs at
the party this woman comes up to me who
like looks kind of familiar because like
the foo fighters like you see pat smear
and you're like yeah i've been
looking at you
on screens for like
my whole life yeah you know what i'm
saying so there's actually like
you're almost not that star struck
because you're like okay like right
right you've been in my life for 30
years and they're like oh my god that's
like pat smear like right right
yeah like when i you know and um like
one of the greatest music i mean what i
mean what do you think pat
pat smear he has an extremely
interesting career because he started
off in a in a punk band the germs that
never made a lot of money or anything
yeah but it's iconic and he got
recruited into
uh the foo fighters
which at the time
nobody thought the foo fighters were
going to be a big band because it was
actually like oh i guess the drummer is
going to try something
but they you know the foo fighters are
as big as any band ever it really i mean
i feel like foo fighters is up there now
with like
you know how successful the foo fighters
is because you forget he was in nirvana
that is actually what i'm saying true
that's how
we don't yeah but that is so wild so
this after pat smear this person comes
up to me and i'm like i know this person
like like like drummers and bassists
from big 90s bands like have you saw
them at the grocery store be like
couldn't tell you exactly but like this
is in my hippocampus somehow and uh this
woman comes up to me who looks so cool
everyone looks so cool oh i know it was
like when you go to a music premiere
which i've done some
is a different level you looked so you
were on you looked very cool you looked
like you belonged there i looked like i
belonged on fucking southern charm on
bravo
i'm not cool enough for music that's not
true you look like i'm fine with it it's
just you norm core like i'm too yeah but
that's what's cool now no it's not okay
fine i'm not gonna disagree with you on
your own show um and uh so this person
comes up to me and i'm like okay who is
this like this person looks familiar and
she's like hi i'm samantha maloney
uh i was the drummer for whole and
motley crew and the character you played
is based on me
and i was like
oh my god i'm so glad i didn't know that
yeah that would have been so much i
would have been so
and by the way i would not have played
it as like
fast and loose and slutty and pound
towny resident of pound town um because
when you're playing a real person
there's like a little bit of a like oh
god they're gonna watch this right if
they know that i know it's like
insulting to them or something so i was
like i'm so glad i didn't know that yeah
um and then also in the bay okay so one
quick story about
doing the studio 666 movie with the foo
fighters is that i get the script and
it's this neighbor who's just sort of
like i mean
like this kind of out of it burnout
hot mess of a woman
who inserts herself where she shouldn't
gets inserted by people she shouldn't
so it's a documentary
and so i'm reading it like this is
amazing this is amazing the there's a
sex scene in it that is like wild don't
care hilarious can't wait
i'll bring my own
jacob's creek a little flask of stutter
home i'll be fine
and then
there's a scene where dave girl's
character comes like i meet him and i'm
like you know gunning to be
you know a backup singer for them you
know what i mean like you're just
waiting your whole life so you know it's
like
they're will forte is in the movie and
he's like hysterical and it's like a lot
of inside jokes about being in a famous
band that even if you're not a famous
man you kind of go like oh my god right
people always trying to slip them demos
and people always trying to like sing
for them to try to like get on yeah and
like all these like desperate people
around them right and so
in the script
i had the original script i had to sing
the heart song
pat try to understand magic man
magic man by heart yeah which i did not
know it like when you hear it i was like
okay i know that song right and um
because i'm a horrible singer and i
don't make no bones about it i was in
the wedding ringers uh movie with kevin
hart uh where i was like a bridesmaid
and kayla coco and josh gad and one of
the
scenes my character was like a
bridesmaid who was like decided to like
sing for the thing and it's awful and
i'm singing i don't remember what it was
and it was
i'm supposed to sing poorly and that's
the joke after the first rehearsal uh i
get a call it's like hey we're gonna
bring in a vocal coach so that you can
sing a little better just so it's
that it's just so it doesn't seem it's
not like sad
like it's it's not reading funny it's
reading just a little like is she all
right that's
like what's the gag here like are we
poking fun at
mentally handicapped look what is this
yeah yeah yeah so then i have to go to a
vocal game it's your choice yeah we just
have to go to vocal coach and they're
like can you just sing a little better
i'm like that that this is me trying
hard to be good yeah and so this one i
was like got it and i really did try to
not like overdo it bad because this
woman would be like kind of good maybe
right right and uh
and
so i just sing magic man uh how does it
go i'm a magic man
yeah
like that song so try to understand
and so i i'm memorizing i get it i get
it and i fully am like okay i'm about to
go sing in front of the foo fighters
with no music
that's a heart song that's wild and i'm
like i can do this like i can do this
like if they had to do comedy in front
of me they'd probably be a little
nervous probably not but i was like i
got this it's just they get it they
hired me i gotta just do this
and by the way not laugh and i have to
like look dave girl in the eyes the
entire time one of the greatest
musicians easily of our lifetime right
legend
and so
i get there and they're like oh hey we
could the licensing for the hard thing
is just it's taking too long it's kind
of a thing we're just gonna have you
sing ever long by the foo fighters
and i was like
i was like i would like to call ronan
farrow oh this is time's up am i like i
will do any sex scene you want yeah like
this is i actually think i can't
physically can't do this yeah
and my you know when your heart like
takes a shit in your chest
for a second i was like what if i just
went home yeah yeah yeah
yeah i i had all these i was like i
might just go home yeah i i was like
what if i just
like fall out of the trailer
i was literally like how do you like
injure yourself like i just was like
literally i was like i have to get out
of this there's no way i can do this and
then um
and then i just
did it and there was thank god like
i locked into one person her name's
adrian she's the makeup artist on the
movie and i just looked at her and
the first time i did it she
like ruined the take by laughing and she
was like you know what like that sounds
like okay as long as it's funny that's
all i care about right but it was
so embarrassing it was i'm having sex
even like watching it last night i was
kind of able to but it was doing it
because
i mean i had to do it for an hour and
here's what else is crazy i was really
hurting my voice so i would like in
between takes like dave or someone try
to talk to me i'm like i'm just i'm on
vocal rest
like i was
i was like i'm just trying to play like
we've created a month i'm just trying to
preserve my voice because i i really am
like i'm going for it yeah the next day
i destroyed my because i don't know
singing is like a muscle you have to
wrestle you can't just do it without
screwing up your you know i mean this
the the notes i hit um and uh
so it is funny i think ultimately but
they're
too for the foo fighters to watch me
just butcher that song like
they were like on like a what was that
like a deck or something like looking
down i was like oh my god
and they're acting of course they were
supposed to act by being like oh god
this sounds awful people like people
clear the sets for nude scenes you're
like you can stay for the new king i
need this stuff clear i know i was like
talking to hr closed set this is a
violent type of embarrassment but then
so they're up so dave is in front of me
it's my single which means like they're
just shooting me and not them right but
they're just there for my eyeliner
and then so they're kind of like oh god
and i remember being like
you guys aren't on camera you don't yeah
you don't have to act like you don't
have to do that and they're like
we're not like
[Applause]
but that's how cool they are
and then okay this is uh at the end of
the night
um
me being the best friend emily's ever
had
by
straight up
murdering a pair of shoes that
hold on was holding her back in life
okay so watch
she was limping around and this pair of
shoes
this is that's well i mean look we're
adults so obviously at the end of the
night uh
we decided to race so
i don't know if this is just a being
from like the dc area thing but at the
end of the night whenever i go out
there's a race
what is that
is that normal pat do you do that with
your friends sometimes like if i'm
if we're going to the car even if it's
like 20 feet right right it's like at
what point in your life are you done
racing to the car no i think the last
time i did it was
probably like 28 years ago 28 years ago
oh okay stars was um like 12 hours ago
it was less it was
the car was so far away and there's when
you're gonna race at the end of the
night there's no you don't even have to
say anything you're just like right you
just look at the other person and you go
and we didn't even know where the car
was we didn't know we did not even know
where the car was okay so this is us
racing wait god
[Laughter]
bullshit
you fucking
you only won because i'm a nice person
i could have beaten you
you dickhead and i didn't cause wait why
didn't
by the way this shit you're dressed like
a cheetah why doesn't this have a
fucking uh
thing on it
you know what
how about this how about this emily
how
i want to say one thing about um it's a
little bit of a wild story but just
because we're talking about horror
movies because
last night when i was sitting through
the foo fighters movie it was it was i
was like why don't i watch more horror
movies this is so fun and so um
and it reminded me of this story because
what else would i tell a story about
like stephen king when i when i wrote
when i was on the book tour for the book
i wrote you do these like book
convention things and i was asked to
like host one of them where it's like
five authors that come up and they speak
and i'm just obviously the idiot just
whatever um and uh
i the one that i did it was
the astronaut who's the astronaut
buzz aldrin thank you together we make a
fully functioning functioning human
um buzz aldrin like some other amazing
people i don't remember
and uh and stephen king
and so we're in the green room before
the show and it's not like an snl green
room or like a like a you know talk show
green room it's like the people that are
have written the book are there it is
right just them right and like their
publicist or something right right um
and uh book publishes are hilarious it's
like they've like knitted all their own
outfits it's so funny and there's like
so much yarn like like like hats and
like you know so much yarn i know i'm
like this is just such a wild world like
so many clogs um and
so stephen king is there which is like
again the same thing with you know maybe
pat smear and the foo fight yeah where
you're like when you see stephen king
you're like
yeah that is a person that's not even an
actor or a writer or i'm sorry or a like
public per that's facebook right like a
famous writer right yes
how many writers could you recognize our
face you're like true that's stephen
king right and so
he everyone's talking to each other he
comes up i'm like just be cool just be
cool and just act like you're cool just
just will smith do it scared i'm like
you can you can do this just ask him
questions about himself
and like stop talk like because you know
when you start embarrassing yourself
when you're talking to someone that
you're trying so hard to not be nervous
that you just talk too much and then out
of your body and you're just looking
down at yourself like hey bitch stop
talking like begging you yeah and like
silence women um so i'm star struck at
stephen king this is stephen king don't
say big fan okay don't say love your
word like right just we're here together
right and we start talking and he just
kind of and he i think he's been stephen
king for so long that he knows to just
come in and
go like how's it going right he made it
very normal very fast of course he's
incredible and then um
there's a guy that is like hovering
behind him that is has pictures of him
like when you leave a premiere people
have pictures that you can sign that
they'll put on ebay and they can make
some money the guy's taking pictures and
i'm like
i'm watching this i'm watching
stephen king
like someone has broke into the green
room
and is hovering around steven like fan
energy man right right right manic fan
energy right and the person is like he's
got all these stephen king merchants and
necklaces and oh jesus like
just wild shit and you can you can just
tell right you know what i'm saying
right and he's like staring at stephen
and he's got a thing and he's like
writing out what stephen's saying and
like taking pictures of him and i'm like
this is like
and i'm like okay be cool don't tell him
because it's obviously going to freak
him out because like this person my
rating is like this one's about like
murder in front of me right on a hinge
and i'm going to have to do a full kevin
costner in the bodyguard i'm gonna have
to run through
and like take a bullet for stephen king
um and
so he's there i don't no one has plus
ones or anything so i'm like okay okay
how are the publicists not right deal
with this i mean this person dressed
like dresses like half the publicist so
that's part of the problem and so that's
funny um and so i was like
freaking out and i was just like you
know what i'm just gonna be honest
because i've seen a lot of crazy shit
happen right with being friends with a
couple of musicians where like stalkers
will get in or dangerous people will get
in or you know and you you just have to
say something right away you can't the
gift of fear we talk about it all the
time you just have to trust your
instinct and my intuition was like this
person is dangerous to this man whether
he's stephen king or not right like this
is dangerous right and the person is not
reading social cue not acknowledging me
or not right you know and because i make
eye contact with him a couple times just
to try to go like
what are you doing right it was like
shifty and you wouldn't look looking at
steven like he's about to like eat him
alive and like
make a you know tube top out of him and
so i'm like
stephen king
i know i don't know you very well
and i know this is very weird
but there is a man behind you
that i believe is stalking you and got
it in and should not be here
and seems very dangerous so i did it
like out of his ears right right so i
was like so how about you and i
how about we like go to the bathroom
yeah and then we can like you just need
to get out of this room yeah like but i
did it like not urgent right if it was a
conversation right you know what i mean
i was like how about like you go to the
left i'll take your place and yeah and
then you go to the bathroom
and then i will notify somebody you know
what i mean yeah and he was like oh no
no no that's um that is one of my
stalkers but i've just accepted the fact
that he follows me everywhere it's been
about 20 years he turns around he's like
oh yeah no no he comes with me
everywhere
i was like
so you're just and he's a guest there's
nothing we can do
daddy he's like i've tried he's like
there's nothing we can do we've tried
everything we've tried restraining
orders we've tried injunctions we've
tried he gets in everywhere everyone
knows about him like he just always gets
in and we don't know how i've just
accepted him and he was like he's
harmless i was like
so this person is just with you all i'm
just again he's like i've just
surrendered
don't get any ideas people
i was like that is like oddly the
sweetest like like at one point
there was a point where he just had to
go like
all right yeah just you and me man this
is part when i was like we've tried
we've gotten security i used to have a
thing and then like every there's no way
just managed to just get a wristband at
a convention center
to get down with four key cards to where
we were and he's like he can do it he'll
make fake wristbands he'll get the key
cards like a villain in a stephen king
movie
literally
so then i'm like i kind of feel like
we're in a stephen king novel or
something yeah and he's like not
interested in writing that
when i worked at david letterman so at
letterman you could only get tickets
once a year whoever you were it's like
if you got a ticket it was once a year
so once a year we had stalker day so
they would invite all of letterman's
stalkers to the show the same day every
year so we'd get them out of the way so
that no stalker could come back at any
other time during the year because we'd
say no you already came this year which
we'd say to anyone who tried to because
i think the thing is like if you give
them something to look forward to right
they'll just focus on that we had as
someone that went on to soccer today and
he was like hey can i do my standover
the entire audience was full of his
stalkers like people that thought they
were married to him people that thought
they were the mother of his child like
psychos so and he's how is he feeling on
that day i don't know if they told him i
honestly don't know
i don't know
that's a really smart thing i know but i
was assigned to this one real
whack-a-doodle who thought she was his
wife and like when but and she was so
convincing that by the end of the
afternoon i was like
maybe this is maybe
maybe he's the jerk i was like maybe
he's just being addicted like full steve
jobs yeah i was like ma'am i'm so sorry
i thought you were a crazy per no like
and my boss was like emily
don't say the c word yeah
it was just like but what is what's her
vibe
it honestly like she just looks like a
normal everyday person normal everybody
scares me more than anything yeah if
you're wearing like a crocheted like
poncho
i'm like
but if it's someone that you're like oh
yeah i mean by the end of the afternoon
i thought she was his wife
like that's how
that was her reality and she pulled me
right into it how old was she she was
probably like in her 40s
like yeah i could have told you that
wasn't his wife
context clues emily you should have put
down sex clues that is fascinating to me
once a year yeah because i tell you i
mean my the stalker the first star i
don't stalkers like
people i just think you're such a
narcissist really i have a struggle
they're mo they're usually not dangerous
usually just like
your gut will tell you like i've had
right people show up at my house like
and uh i just like called their parents
and sent them home you know they're not
well people and also my thing is that if
you can't fight off your own stalker you
don't deserve to be famous like have
them just like pull it together like
okay you know i don't know i just i
don't i think most of them are not
dangerous but i think that what was the
thing that happened in the 80s 70s with
that sitcom girl there is something
standard like had a nightmare situation
but like i don't think anyone's gonna
kill go to jail for me i'm not that much
of a narcissist but um there was that
because stalkers normally it's not too
personal like usually it's like they'll
move on to another person yeah and then
they'll move on to someone else like
it's just like a fixation kind of thing
right and um the first time i had
someone calling me this was like 12
years ago and this guy would just call
me calling me a comment like i would get
out of meeting up like 60 missed calls
it was like in this first time i've ever
been through this like i was like on
like mtv or something right like it was
very new to me um and then any man would
call me back much less 60 times in a row
i'm like what are you complaining about
and but he had a very
very uh consistent narrative he's like
it's like me we were supposed to meet on
the sony lot 20 minutes ago where are
you like i'm looking like he was like
yeah like you're saying he was very
convinced yeah so you were probably like
oh my god
oh my god like like i i am
absolutely where's my drive off yeah i
had like ambient at the time i was like
surprised i'm so sorry man
and so uh so he would call call call and
then
uh i would answer and he would like hang
up and freak out so finally the la
pd
comes over they have a detective at the
time in order to get a stalker's
location you had to keep them on the
phone for like three minutes back in the
20s
it was very annoying it was you i i
don't know what that technology is so i
had to keep on the phone so they trained
me they were like you have to agree with
his reality yeah you know whatever and
i'm like i take improv i can do this yes
right and so because we have to figure
out where he is we have to keep him on
the phone for three minutes maybe it's a
little yeah don't disagree with him if
he says i'll see you later today go yep
can't wait like we're here you're safe
it's fine so i was like okay i can do
this i can do this
and then he calls i pick up
totally i'm like i'm
nailing it yeah he's saying the craziest
things i'm like oh my god i know i'm so
sorry like i know we were going to go to
cincinnati earlier
you know whatever everybody's like mad
at me about things that i haven't done
and then uh the la the detector whatever
looks at me and mouths like we got it oh
okay three minutes
right and then i was like uh okay
you got it like i said something like
that and he's sort of or i was like okay
um
i just like broke i guess right right
you know and i was i didn't know how to
get off the phone yeah yeah yeah didn't
tell me how to dismount this thing
i'm now dating this person and like kind
of a little help like and then i just
like was like i have to leave and then
he was like i was like i should go and
he was like well i'm gonna like
never heard from him again
talk to someone for three minutes
one week later
detective calls me
great news
your stalker has moved on
to another public figure
and i was like
who is she
i don't like i don't care i'm just
curious yeah like i was like i feel like
i just deserved to know yeah and he was
like yeah we can't tell you that and i
was like
why not like i just want to know like
don't shouldn't i i cuz i could warn her
i could like let her know what to say
ma'am stalker filed a restraining order
against you no no then i go to his
instagram
whitney i'm like looking at who he
follows yeah like who's who's whose
photos he's liking with celebrities he
follows like tried and i'm like i'm
fully stalking my oh yeah you're stuck i
still i think about them all the time
i'm like what did i say on that call
just let me know like my thing so you
don't do it again just let me know i'm
just curious what
made you go pushed him over the edge i'm
just curious no that is com i would be
too that's very human it's very i i
think about it all the time i now i want
to know i know what's his instagram
handle i have it well we because we had
to do a background check on him and he
did have a hunting license so oh dear
they were like you need to stop because
he can by the way he would dm me and i
would read them and i didn't know it
said text scene like 10 i was checking
his text like the second he sent them
and they're like you have to stop he can
see that you're like ma'am we can't
protect you if you don't want to protect
yourself help us help you like this is
like you're embarrassing yourself
wait okay so when i that reminds me okay
oh no i have a bit of a drunk dialing
problem like i'll get drunk and then
drunk not like if i dated you then i
will call you doesn't matter how long
it's been doesn't matter how many times
you don't pick up just
there was one yeah yeah it's it's that
is a kind of
i think a part of your amygdala just
shuts down yeah and then you lose count
it's like when i take edibles i'm like i
don't know how many i've taken right and
then i'm ready i think it's two it's 30.
and then i'm real squirrelly because
i'll delete it when i'm drunk so i wake
up in the morning and don't see that i
called someone like 17 times right so it
was getting really bad when i lived in
new york i was like 25 i was dating this
guy named buddy and i would just like
call him it wasn't his name but yeah no
really was that that's on his license
yes okay i would just call him over and
over again so one morning i called 18t
and i put 18t smart limits on my phone i
don't know about that which is at the
time was like a thing that basically
parents did for teenagers phones which
was they blocked a number so that number
could not reach out to you like you paid
4.99 a month 4.99 a month the number was
blocked so i guess if your kid was like
if you wanted your kid not being in
touch with another kid or whatever so i
changed the number blocked so he blocked
kevin spacey's number so he could not
call me
no you could not call him okay
i thought that oh no
so
i am still calling him constantly drunk
thinking
he doesn't get it right
but then my friend was like no no that
only works one way so i called 18t and i
was like i have to find out if if these
calls are going through so i called 18t
and i was like hey i put um i have a
stalker
i put smart limits on my phone it's 4.99
a month i was just calling to see like
what happens when i call my stalker and
they're like ma'am
or misunderstanding the question what i
was like when i
i pay monthly to block someone why are
you lying to a shit what happens when i
call them and he goes ma'am why would
you call your stalker and i was like
it's not important i need to know if the
calls are going i just need to know if
he called me earlier to confirm he's a
soccer he puts me on hold he comes back
20 minutes later he's like man we've
never had anyone ask us this
i don't have an answer for you we're
gonna give you we're gonna pay your next
phone bill like as an apology for not
knowing
well
this is a new problem that has never
happened and will never happen again
i was paying five dollars a month to
block him and then calling him it's also
just such a there's so many better lies
out there
like jeremy like i blocked my ex and now
i need to call him because he has
something i need
so i was sitting at work making this
phone call and my co-worker was like
you need help like he heard ben my work
at bed here and he's like you need
you're way worse than i but wait so what
happened what happened was is that
there's no still no answer i don't know
you don't know if buddy got about nobody
got the calls or not have you heard from
him and he probably did i think he did
i've not heard from it yeah i mean yeah
he was 11 years ago but i've not i've
never heard buddy if you're a fan of the
pod
i'm so sorry
we now take a break to talk to you about
um
you know
i
am gonna say something that no one's
gonna believe
okay
possibly
my the the most unbelievable thing i've
said yet which is that
i'm just gonna say it
i can't cook
i know
that is gonna come as a shock to you
so
doordash
the point is i don't have to feel bad
anymore that i don't have time to cook
i've got shit to build i've got stuff to
do i've got instagrams to post i've got
uh selfies to take
you know i've got a relationship to try
to salvage i've 100 dogs i've got a
uterus that is just
you know
just the fourth day
of an avocado
you know what i mean and i don't have
time to run around and try to prove that
i can cook door dash and i also like
lots of different food i'm finally at a
point in my life where i don't restrict
my eating the way i used to and i have a
lot of lost time to make up for it takes
the stress off my life
it shows up there's never drama with
door dash get what you want to eat right
now and right to your door with doordash
along with restaurants you love you can
also get groceries and other essential
items delivered to your door with door
dots you can get drinks snacks and other
household items in under an hour with
over 300 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
popeyes chipotle and cheesecake factory
ordering is so easy and your items will
be left safely outside your door when
you choose contactless delivery drop-off
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
gfy
and spend your time instead of making
dinner making drinks like this little
treat i made myself which is a
radioactive green which is uranium and
uh
tequila
that's 25 off up to 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the door dash app in the
app store and enter code gfy don't
forget that's code gfy for 25 off your
first order with doordash subject to
change terms apply
so speaking of my neon green drink
uh i love green drinks
she only drinks grapes i only drink
green drinks if you don't think i've
done athletic greens in tequila you're
wrong um now one thing we talked about
winning a lot is the optimizing you're a
big optimizer you know that when i was
in my 20s i only wore velcro shoes
because in my brain i went like every
time you tie your shoes that's like 30
seconds and i multiplied it and i was
like that's like
eight or nine hours you would spend
tying your shoes so what is this stuff
with one delicious scoop of athletic
greens you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole foods source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right athletic
green supports mental clarity and
alertness tons of people take some kind
of multivitamin and it's important to
choose one with high quality ingredients
that your body will actually absorb
sorry flintstones it's cheaper than
getting all your different supplements
yourself right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into the flu and cold
season
it's just one scoop and especially
especially entering into your whole face
it's just one scoop in a cup of water
every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health to make it
easy athletic greens is giving you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
again that is at lettergreens.com
whitney and here's what was that you
already know about atletico you already
know about it you hear about it on big
fancy podcasts
let today be the day if you're looking
for a sign of like i really got to order
that like i have been meaning to do that
i know you've been meaning to do it so
let's do it just do it right now because
you're wasting my time and everybody
else's time that's not by staying
unhealthy you're not allowed to be
unhealthy anymore it's boring it's
unoriginal you
there's no excuse for that yeah again
grow up again that's
get athletic athleticgreens.com
and invest in your future self again
that's that's athleticgrease.com i need
to take ownership of your health and
pick up the ultimate nutritional
insurance yeah i remember it was in my
last special that um i i said something
about like when you guys call women
crazy like like we know some women are
crazy like we see the text she didn't
send like
we've all gone through that thing where
were we misjudged
like just pick up i'm just gonna call
again yeah so that you don't have to
use your minutes right there was a timer
calling someone cost money i was always
calling after midnight so nights and
weekends
there's a time where when you were in
like immature toxic relationships where
you would call and it was just like i'm
gonna keep calling you gotta keep
calling keep calm and it was just like
cutting yourself was like hurting
yourself it was just like making it so
bad that it would never work out in a
weird way it's like self-sabotaging yeah
and also just like i mean i have the ocd
stuff too where i'm just going to keep
calling you keep going and
you don't want me to not keep calling
because at least if i'm calling you 50
times i'm not at your house
in a wedding dress
like you'd rather be called because also
my mother know where i am because also
in my head it's like i'm gonna call
again yeah right fine we're broken up
yeah you know what i'm just gonna get
closure yeah all right you didn't answer
again yeah that's like you're a lot of
times you're just collecting data do you
know what i'm saying yeah and the
phone's probably off
i i wish it doesn't show you called when
your phone's off fuck
anyway i mean i don't respond even from
work text if you guys don't respond to
me i won't send another text like i am
like
so terrified of setting like two texts
in a row that haven't been responded to
because i definitely had my fair sorry i
just had coffee
okay so
that is that we're um you know i'm on
tour uh quite a lot uh coming up we are
gonna have to uh reschedule the
cincinnati date because i don't know
exactly what's going on with these
airlines
but i had a connection to cincinnati
from l.a the connection would have got
me in at seven the show was at eight
would have made it with flying colors
but it was two hours delayed then three
hours delayed they made me cancel it
we've had a lot of mechanical failures a
lot of a lot of and also there are very
few flights now because people are just
flying less in general so there's not
i'm like trying to get to cincinnati and
it's like there's two flights a day yeah
and i have to do a connection so i was
gonna find um
which really sucks and i'm i'm sorry
that happened and i'm having people just
text me if you need refunds for parking
or for a babysitter or whatever
go to american airlines.com
uh
8182397527 was that beep that was your
you got an email i had an email what
gotta go
um
oh name
you guys i can't talk nancy pelosi just
emailed me wait a second it's the rnc
uh so couple other things uh i will be
in grand rapids michigan at 20 monroe
live
uh i didn't see the date of that pat
sorry uh soon um on march 5th march 18th
portland me at the maryland auditorium
that's the romaine the maryland sure
whatever god you are so like oh so picky
you're sorry oh my god uh give an inch
much 19th of march i'll be in laconia
new hampshire it's a fake place i'm
being kidnapped it's a prank but i'll be
at the colonial theater uh march 25th
i'm gonna be a new haven connecticut at
the college street music hall albany new
york i'll be at the egg march 26th at
least there'll be one egg somewhere
uh april 1st austin texas paramount
theater you're going to come to that oh
yeah dallas texas april 2nd this is all
on whitneycomings.com go to it i am
shooting also my next stand-up special
in a little city called newark new
jersey
cannot wait may 13th and 14th and so uh
the tickets are not on sale yet but they
will be soon um we're gonna shut up
because today's guest is amanda seals
you know her from insecure on hbo
obviously uh her first stand-up comedy
special is ib no one that is also an hbo
i loved it and then her book is small
doses potent truths for everyday use uh
i love this i've got many a bookmark in
here um she also has a podcast called
small doses and i was listening to it
i was like binging it because she
interviews artists like about their
process and she did one with amy
sherrold who's my
i mean i think the best artist working
right now not that i know that much
about art but she's i saw her work
downtown in person and it was like
i should quit everything i'm doing like
if i'm not
making stuff this
incredible i mean and then she talks
about her process it changed my life i
listened to it when i was in i don't
remember where i was but i was just like
i was like taking notes on a podcast
it's that it's that insightful good
poignant it'll like change you um she
also uh her patreon smart funny and
black smart funny black radio
go to smartphoneblack.com
all this is on that website she also has
a union newsletter um it should all be
on there
and in terms of this episode this uh you
know conversation with her i did
hopefully i've always been clear about
how i want this podcast
the whole point of this podcast was to
make episodes that were really funny and
irreverent and like being a fly on the
wall of comedians talking and being
vulnerable and you know i wanted to be
really funny i wanted to make a show
that made you you know forget your
problems and you know some episodes
where you're going to learn something
and you have access to neuroscientists
or you know doctors or whatever um
because our thing here is good for you
we're always in school like you're never
cooked and uh i just wanted to like i
said about when i wrote my book i want
to be like the robin hood of like mental
health and stuff so it's like you know
here's all the stuff i've learned like
let me just you know right i want to
make the show that i wish was available
to me when i was like 20. you know and
uh but we also uh have always been very
open about wanting to have episodes that
may be uncomfortable at times but also
just the kind of conversations that
you know are important and they need to
be had because that's the only way you
can change and
staying the same is gross
so gross yeah right 1000
please enjoy miss amanda
can we go pat good to go great so um we
jump right in uh i don't mean to cut you
off but i do want to just say i normally
i open this podcast with asking the
guests if we're friends and the guest
gets to answer
i don't even know you
but the guest gets to answer
because what i don't like is this false
sense of fake familiarity when you go on
a podcast and someone's like this is my
best friend amanda seals like that's a
white girl thing and then
that's an absolute oh my god i love you
guys i love you
i know that it's like literally like
it's like you're not you like i get it
and i'm like okay that's like a very la
thing i just like to yeah like
create a space where what's actually
happening is happening and no one has to
be fake and perform because i've been in
situations where i'm walking on a
podcast and i'm like i just have to be
very clear we've never met this person's
acting like we have and like oh really
well and i like you but it's just we
this is odd because
but do they have a family is it like the
whole fan thing where they have a film
familiarity with you by nature of you
them knowing your work well i think it's
more they'll go like so this is my good
friend whitney
whitney where are you from
or maybe would you have taken the time
out to maybe google that because that's
a google question do you have any new
questions for me like i'm really trying
to think i don't think i've had that
experience but i also think that because
i'm sure we're going to talk about some
stuff that is going to get a little
dicey because that's what you and i both
do
so i'm very excited about this um and i
just
i don't want people being like oh but
they're already good friends and you
know it just it is what it is and i'm a
fan i'm going to just i mean if we were
friends they would have seen you on my
instagram by now
interesting
i mean this is yeah
yeah
that's interesting most of my friends
aren't on my instagram i mean i mean the
way that i have existed until this point
like yeah people know who my friends are
yeah
okay now all my friends are like why
don't you put me on your instagram
because that's not how you you know
instagram god that's what you know i
mean listen
working for it i wasn't
real friends because
there was a situation that had happened
and they like didn't
address it with me directly in the right
way like they just didn't and they and i
was like i had to hit them like
what did y'all see what happened and
it's like yeah
and it's like oh you're watching my
instagram like it's a tv show but it's
an actual real thing that's happening so
to me like if i see somebody even if i
see something cryptic on someone's
instagram i call them like what's up
like
if i see you on instagram like you know
i'm just you know
taking time for me what the fuck is up
what's up yeah yeah totally
totally this this is not your bag sounds
like you're not getting a lot of likes
and you're pivoting to like try to do a
fake retirement thing like jc yeah like
when you need a promo
so i will i don't i i'm hyper
vigilant
i also it's funny when i hang up like
good friends of mine and they asked me
what i'm up to and i'm like so you muted
me over the panda
you can unmute me it's fine i it's i i
agree
by the way i agree you were right this
is why we're friends you have good taste
and good boundaries but you gotta mute
me because i can't recap all of that all
of it you know what i mean so it's there
for you but i just um i also i'm just i
like to be very straight up when i'm
like a fan of someone i've been a fan of
yours since you were on mtv2 wow yup i
had a whole other name
i used to work with yeah amanda diva i
used to work at a waitress at a
restaurant that would play just mtv2 all
the time and that was like very big when
i was in college in philadelphia like it
was just always on everywhere so i was
tonight yeah so i've known you for a
minute i'm just gonna say really quick
um uh you know not only um
have you seen uh amanda insecure
like
i mean
people that hate everyone love you on
that joe
people who doesn't don't give any
credit that is not overly do is like
yeah she was great on that show i really
appreciate it like haters love you on
the show and i'm gonna say something
really quick just about that it really
bothers me that in most of your
interviews the entire interview is about
people that have notes for you and yeah
it's a fucking it is so to me see i'm
glad you're saying that because i was
like oh god do we have to talk about the
people that disagree with it like i
don't it's 10 people no one everyone
loves you it's not true it's very much
giving
it really is giving like you need to
please everyone it triggers my
perfectionism addressing it is
dignifying people that are just jealous
or racist which they don't deserve any
engagement so
i guess to me okay so thank you i feel
very relieved that we don't have to
spend this week if you want to hear her
talk about it um just go watch her on
the breakfast club um yes so uh uh
hollywood unlocked
um she's very she elucidates very
clearly why people criticize her and
addresses beautifully and incredibly
elegant what happens to the ego when
someone
accidentally while pointing out a truth
shames you and makes you feel
embarrassed because i think when you
point out something that is correct uh
you did it a couple times in my
stairwell here earlier when you get
embarrassed of your behavior because
someone's holding a mirror up to you you
get embarrassed and then your ego wants
to go well she's she's obnoxious she's
loud she's like and i've done the same
like i think that's just a very human
nature thing
i feel like
what happens is
the next step of that is growth and
being able to identify like oh i'm doing
that
they're not doing that to me
like like they're saying something
generically that i am attaching to
and i am now feeling the need to react
and respond and it's like
this is all you that's like that's like
acknowledging a like when a
puppy pees on the carpet like
negative reinforcement is the only thing
that works like ignoring it is the only
thing that works because if they're
getting attention for it they just learn
this is how i'm gonna get amanda's
attention i'm just going to like say
shit about her i cannot get my dog to
potty training okay we'll we'll talk
about that okay um that is that is i'm
the amanda seals
so jordy is killing me okay i want to
talk about this in a minute um because i
do think that your journey training your
puppy is going to be part of your
journey with disengaging from feedback
on the internet and when you so i have
started
i've started that journey listening to
you on other people's podcasts has made
me like irate because number one i don't
like when people come on especially that
have the kind of like life force you
have the kind of um time constraints you
have and the kind of work that needs to
that you want to get done given in our
limited time here you spend so much time
either saying what you've always already
said on your podcast small doses and
they ask you questions you've already
talked about so if you want to talk
about her departure from the real if i'm
sorry hear about that or if you want to
hear about um her uh the depression that
came along with that if you want to hear
about any of that drama just uh you can
listen to her on jamil jamie's podcast
she said it she said it on and or if you
want to talk hear about her miscarriage
just listen to small doses here we're
going to talk about things she has not
talked about before
um even though i just i'm so annoyed
that so much of your time and bandwidth
has been spent on the people that
that
have criticized there's it's so small
most people
don't respond at all they just go oh she
makes a good point and they show it to
their friend like that's the take
that's most people's response to you
i like
i had to train my audience though like
i need y'all to say good stuff because
the people with saying the bad stuff are
louder totally totally but also like if
people said the good stuff people like
us perfectionist comedians i'm a verse
you're a cancer you'll be rising you're
not gonna you're not saying i'm double
no i have to force myself actually i'll
catch myself but you're rolling past a
like very kind comment and we'll tell
and i'm like stop
go back
read those kind words and then what are
you going to think you're just going to
go well she's just saying that because i
told him they should
no i don't do that really i'm like no
you do work okay because i appreciate
you they'll go like you did a great job
and i'm like not an awesome job
and you don't think i'm pretty like i
will find a way to make a compliment an
insult by like what they omitted and
i'll just find a way to keep hurting
myself with your like kind feedback
maybe that's work i need to do maybe
i think for me though
as someone
like i just i have a i am just committed
to the idea that i just i'm sure i have
blind spot like there's just no way i
don't you're a white woman in america
what how dare you
every first of all every white person in
america is
racist off rip by nature of the fact
that this is a racist country off-rip so
you know even so many black folks find
themselves perpetuating white
supremacist stuff
by nature of the fact that it's just so
ingrained into the very fabric of this
nation and the globe even if you're a
zombie and have been programmed and are
just walking through life you're still
benefiting from racist institutions so
it takes a hi it takes consciousness to
be able to say okay
i'm going to be anti-racist and that's
when the work begins about around
something like that it takes
consciousness to be able to be like oh
toxic masculinity is a thing that i
don't want to perpetuate so many of us
like think that we are being feminists
or we think we're being womanists and
we're not realizing just like ways that
we didn't even
ways that we are
unintentionally perpetuating
perpetuating toxic masculinity because
it's so it's just deep so yeah you have
blind spots we all have blind spots and
then also just so you can um take a
breath because i do want to get to talk
a little bit about um with your
permission interracial uh dating cats
versus dog the state of hip-hop and
white rappers um
i like the agenda
in no particular order but uh what she's
saying in her book small doses which is
kind of a little bible here uh at the
good for you podcast on page 61 um she
talks about the the white people litmus
test and some some ways that you can
get started uh if dangerous minds is
your favorite movie i have bad news for
you
um and then on page 62 the white alley
ally most i mean a lot of white girls
are named ali wait white alley
well no the reason why that's funny is
because there is a letter in there to
white folks yeah from my friend allison
short ally
that is wild so and then uh some of the
films that that we have to take a second
look at uh freedom writers if it wasn't
for that
green book uh it's like just you know i
hate green books so much and then um
yeah that that
you know oh it's so wild the um
let's talk about that in in a second
because i definitely am gonna um there's
so much i want to talk to you about but
i just did want to uh
bring up uh just a couple of my blunders
or my um
uh quite like you know i think i've
heard a lot of like
but i date interracial i can't be racist
or you know because white people i think
are getting so defended not all of them
that's the other thing i think we do
when we talk about the stuff we're like
everyone thinks everyone's mad at me
it's you know
not everyone but when
i like reflect back on
like interracial relationships i've been
in and at this point
i think that for me personally the only
validation i'm kind of going for is
black women if a black woman is like
what you're doing is you're using your
platform like then you're like all right
i must be doing something right if
they're if they don't then you got to
take a look in the mirror i just that's
for now for now you know that could
change like gay men are also like a real
good black gay man yeah so it's like if
and then if you can have them come on
the podcast and then say here's what
you're not doing right and reach a
different audience because when i was
listening to you on the um uh hollywood
break
down break ground right did i get that
right
i feel like i've done so many you've
done so it's shocking to me was that
with was that the hollywood unlocked
unlocked i'm sorry yes i called it the
breakdown there was a conversation about
um why are you know is all the press
variety in hollywood reporter why not
coming to black media sources and the
first thing my brain
said which i was like
tell me if this is ignorant is like
because like there is a point where
like preaching to the choir there's only
there's only so much you can do like do
you want to get
like how do you approach
white platforms are you like i should go
on that platform so i can reach people i
wouldn't normally reach or am i
supporting a white platform that
shouldn't be so white
by
participating and that do you know what
i'm saying like i think it depends on
what
you're talking about yeah right like
when i
um
had to gather caitlyn jenner in her
ignorance
uh
that
needed to be
discussed
on a white platform yeah um do you not
know about this i feel like i'm
literally like
so
i know a little bit about 17 i went to a
dinner
that katy perry had
uh
to promote her book i mean to promote
her album eyewitness or witness and uh
there was whiteness
hilarious and so she wanted to have like
this dish she was having like these
dinners and this was a dinner originally
it was dinner with friends and i was
like i might i don't know none of these
people so why is it called dinner with
friends i think it should be called
dinner with discourse because the whole
point of the dinner was that katie had
voted for hillary and her parents have
voted for trump and she was like i don't
want to go home for thanksgiving because
i don't know how to have these
conversations so she's both terrible
choices
so can we have a dinner where like yeah
we kind of see what it's like to have
conversations with people who have
different opinions than you so it was
like me and navarro first of all it's
like you have parents stop bragging
your parents should love you easy and
you're complaining i have to talk to my
parents on a holiday i love you katie
margaret show
sally cohn
um
this dj dj skeeter and then katy perry
and then uh
van jones and
um
[Music]
caitlyn jenner and so
at one point in the dinner i was saying
well there was a lot of kumbayashi and
at one point in the dinner i was like
you know i i i don't subscribe to the
kumbayanese of it all like everyone kept
saying like everyone's opinion matters
you know we need to care about
everyone's opinion and then eventually
van is like amanda what do you think i
was like i don't think everyone's
opinion matters i think
for anyone who voted for trump i know
what your opinion is and i
you literally are putting me in harm's
way you're by placing that vote your
actions say you don't give a fuck about
black women you don't give a fuck about
a number of groups right so you can talk
about women um so
i was like i don't want to honor that
and i also feel like trump is uh
on a trajectory a hitler-esque
trajectory and they were like oh my god
how do you say that that's crazy
and
you know caitlyn was very upset
uh she was very upset and she was just
like you know how
i'm looking at it now i'm looking at
your body language in these pictures and
it's stressing me out she was just like
how dare you i'm like what katelyn used
to be a marathon runner she just
sprinted out of that dinner real fast
she was very emboldened though she was
emboldened because everybody was babying
her
because she was the trans person in the
room
that
but my thing was like she is the trans
person in the room and that needs to
have a space sure but you're also the
right-wing republican who spent majority
of your life pushing and perpetuating
like white male bullshit so like there's
also space for that and in that
conversation she was basically telling
me that you know
america has treated her so well that she
would never say any of these things and
i had to
in a very succinct way let her know like
we haven't had the same experience sure
and she scoffed at by the way i also
want to i always want to um reference
robin tran brilliant um trans female
comedian i know we shouldn't have to
qualify that but um she uh is uh
vietnamese and she has this amazing joke
first of all she's like i'm such a lazy
she goes i'm such a lazy trans woman
that my uh email is robert tran
gmail.com like she's like i don't have
enough money to transition like i can't
like she's just like in a dress and like
just puts on red lipstick but she says
she's like the reason that um white
trans women are so entitled and
obnoxious because they became a double
minority overnight they used to be a
white man and she's like i was a
vietnamese man and i transitioned to a
vietnamese woman so i went up you know
so that's her joke not mine you know and
uh and you know and i you know the
podcast we had with um uh lady j
um and jim norton and gigi gorgeous last
week about
transitions it's like
the whole point of being equal as a
trans person is you're equal to the same
feedback and criticism and people making
jokes about you if they're homophobic
that's a different story you're
transphobic that's different but you
still have to be held at the same
standards like you don't get special
treatment just because you're trans in
fact
you know there's a little bit of an onus
going you've decided to be a public
figure
and like now you have to do your
homework and you don't get to be
ignorant anymore like and
just listen just listen
and be willing to be wrong because you
have a platform
but
not a fan they're obsessed with you but
also uh one thing about katy perry which
i've never told the story and i love her
i've no no i don't know her well but she
always seems like
uh a sweet pea
and one time we were at some event
together in new york and i had gotten
my nails done and they were gray with
like a neon
tip okay like i was just trying
and we sat next to each other in an
event and she looked at my nails and she
went oh ikea colors
i was like
i
i know you don't mean that
in a minute but also you understand to
me that's a huge compliment i love ikea
like but it was like such a true yeah it
was like you know what ouch and thank
you like
taking another break from amanda green
chef
a company is not going to put green on
the front of their name unless they're
ready to walk the walk
and green chef does that
green chef is a ccof certified meal kit
company green jeff makes eating well
easy with plans to fit every lifestyle
whether you're keto paleo vegetarian
gluten-free or just pretending to be one
of those green chef offers a range of
crystal peas to suit your preferences
and the person you pretend to be
green chef is pre-proportioned it means
you'll actually reduce your food waste
by at least 25 percent compare to
grocery shopping where you're a wasteful
dick pics
green chef's pre-made and pre-measured
sauces dressings and spices get you more
chef curated flavor in less time green
chef offers 35 nutritious and flavorful
options to choose from every week is it
a nutrious
no 35 nutritious
is nutrients a word no
nutritious
bummer what chaos is this
flavorful options to choose from every
week featuring premium clean ingredients
peak freshness peak freshness peak i use
green chef and i love it green chef is
now owned by hellofresh and with a wider
array of meal plans to choose from
there's something for everyone i love
switching between the brands and now our
listeners can enjoy both brands at a
discount go to
greenchef.comwhitney130 and use
codewhitney130 to get 130 off plus free
shipping what's nutmeg that's
greenchef.com
whitney130 and use code windows fuck
clothes
don't get me started up close
i want to
and use code whitney130 they have
needles on the end of them to get a
hundred and thirty dollars off plus free
shipping the number one kids are eating
well only needed to be used back when
meat was putrefying and they just had to
use spices to cover the rotting smell
and taste hot take so here's my deal
with furniture
and someone that just furnished a home
and cannot believe the racket racket of
furniture you're paying
for them to rent retail space
in fancy so that you're add that and
then they're going to advertise and
they're going to take ads and vogue and
whatever magazine they're going to pay
for that and then they're gonna take out
ads on jimmy fallon and whatever shows
and then you're paying for that so
something that should cost five hundred
dollars now sudden costs fifteen hundred
dollars to the person who's like well
why am i paying for your ads for the
market to people that aren't buying from
you because i'm the one that's here why
are we here why am i getting punished
articles team of designers focuses on
beautifully crafted pieces quality
materials and durable construction
inspired by a variety of modern design
aesthetics like mid-century scandinavian
industrial and bohemian it's fair prices
you save up to 30 off over traditional
retail prices articles able to keep
their prices low by cutting out the
middleman and selling directly to you no
showrooms no sales people no retail
markups fast affordable shipping is
available across the usa and canada and
is free on orders over 999. articles
offering our listeners 50 off your first
purchase of 100 or more go to
article.com whitney and discount will be
automatically applied at checkout that's
article.com whitney to get 50 off your
first purchase of 100 or more and
hopefully i don't distract my puppy
because he's going to destroy all my
article furniture in here
and i hope we don't have to do any
cutaways during that because whitney is
on the floor playing with her puppy
trying to protect my article furniture
back to amanda seals i guess like i just
um you know in
trying to just figure out the person i
need to be to be in the good graces of
black women i when i i
as a kid you know i grew up in dc you
know what you need to be yeah
you need to be
exactly what
black women have had to be we have to be
twice as perfect we have to be twice as
great we have to be twice as strong we
have to be twice as focused we're
strained and you as a white woman have
to be all of those things about
anti-racism
there's no
lazy version there's no like pedestrian
version you have to be twice as loud
you're going to have to
you know um there's going to be friends
you lose there's going to be spaces that
no longer accept you like you have to be
willing
and
that is a thing that most folks just
can't even envision like let alone like
actually put into practice but that's
the conversations that white people who
are really about anti-racism who are
really about like
challenging the capitalist like uh
heteronormative patriarchy that really
creates space for them to thrive like
those are the conversations you all need
to be having amongst yourself like how
do we push each other how do we because
if you're not going to feel safe having
it come from others then it has to come
from each other and you all have to be
pushing yourselves because honestly
black people are tired of pushing well
here's what it is i mean it's it's yeah
it's exhausting yeah when david yellow
was on it was like you know
you know we you know talked about like
racism is not a black it's not black
people's problem it's a white problem
and white people need to solve it if
black people could solve it it'd be
solved you know and so it's like
and and here's here's my question just
as as as you know someone that struggles
with okay
do what do what do you do in silence
what do you do in in in public and like
wendy williams when when he you know
wendy's been struggling with
some stuff i know people have lots of
opinions on wendy williams uh you know
she's someone that you know i just you
know
they asked me to co host her show when
she was sick recently and i was like i
don't need to do that it's i and i was
like you know what she supported me
before i love her i'm sure she's you
said a lot of crazy shit that's kind of
what she does and i i don't even know
enough about her canon of work to know
what she said that's
problematic or not um and i was like you
know what i'm gonna i think the the best
use of me in any of the late night or
daytime spaces is to be able to
surrender the opportunity so you know if
ellen's like you want to come on i'm
like i've been on there i don't need to
go on there anymore i don't really think
it even moves the needle for me but you
know it would be great nicole buyer you
know it'd be great phoebe or whoever
right and so i was like okay this is i
don't need to do this honestly it's like
i know i'm gonna get a bunch of shit for
it and i'm just gonna get death threats
and shit um but i'm just gonna go on
under the
conceit or the auspices that they let me
have like a black woman co-host like
what like and i had jose sloane and miss
pat for two and michelle beto for two
who
maybe would have gotten it on their own
down the line but at that time you know
so
that's what i did and then
you know maybe i magnified it and it was
hilarious and they're you know
and they should have been doing it alone
frankly but it just wasn't
for whatever reason that wasn't what was
happening and uh with no judgments i
think wendy just wanted to bring on
people that she had been on the show a
lot that she they knew you know and so
um
and then it was like i got a little bit
of shit like oh we got it you have black
friends and it was like
i mean there's always going to be yeah i
was like okay i guess i
you know i don't know it was like
but that that is a part of the path yeah
martin luther king jr had like a 27
don't quote me approval rate when he
passed away i mean it was yeah so well
when he was assassinated i apologize
jesus when he was
murdered and assassinated prematurely uh
by and his life was taken prematurely by
the system but
it's on me it becomes it becomes like
that's just what it is i mean but it's
also as i'm saying it
what i would say to someone else a white
person in private is like
it's on me to tolerate that discomfort
yes it is it's okay to be uncomfortable
because white people are so used to
being comfortable all the time and then
getting some feedback like you know and
and i guess i just wanted to you know i
talked about a little about with ms pat
when i dated uh uh
i had interrogation relations when i was
younger when you didn't even really know
what was happening you was like it was
you would like just go to their house
and see different shit in the fridge but
there was you were too young to even
know
what was happening you know
i remember leaving uh a guy's house that
i was dating um
uh when i was younger who's black and i
remember his mom saying like you can't
wear a hoodie out of the house
and i didn't under i didn't understand
what that meant you know i was too young
right i was too young to understand what
was happening and uh and then his
sisters would make fun of me and bully
you know i like i just was like i'm just
younger you know and then
i i didn't understand till later when we
would walk through a restaurant when i
dated a black man like five years ago
and we'd walk through restaurants and it
was like what the fuck are you i just
remember being like this is a
like do you not understand what's
happening and he was like yeah this is
just my life all the time and it was
like we'd walk on an airplane and
everyone was like and i was like yeah
what are you looking at i was like
trying to fight with everybody and he
was like
you have like i can't even
this is just like i don't even notice
that anymore right
and this is regular but
where
because but when we would walk into a
black space all the black women were
like
you need to get the fuck out of here and
i was like
oh like
you know do you i just i don't know i
guess i just am curious what's the
question the question is like what
how do you feel when you see a white
woman dating a black man it depends on
who she is okay
it depends on who she is depends on who
he is and
you know
i think that godfrey talks a lot about
this and he's like you know we love to
say things like love is love and love
conquers all but
that is
a fake
response to like the true advancement or
lack of advancement of us as a society
like we
still very much can't recognize when
there's a feticide when there's a
fetishizing going on we still very much
can't recognize when we are
individualizing somebody without without
actually understanding that like we
still hold the same prejudices for other
people but we've but we've chosen this
person so like people love to be like oh
like that's the whole thing about the
black friend like or how can i be how
can i be racist if i'm dating a black
person it's like you've come to know
this person yeah interpersonally that's
different
than you supporting a system of course
in fact you probably sit on the bench
because you're like i suck black deck so
i can sit on the bench i'm good i've
done my part where it's like that's not
actual activism and i also remember and
this is something that there's no way
this is not going to get cut up and
make get me canceled but um you know
when he would be at my house and friends
would come over or like four or five
friends that were white and it was just
him
the way that my white friends would that
i've known for
20 years
engaged with him was totally dif like
when people talk to him they would like
start bouncing
and it was like
his presence is affecting
everyone in here people would i remember
i used to work for a late night talk
show my first job as a writer
and when black guests will come on all
of a sudden he'd be like yeah so when
does your album drop
hey bro and it was like you never say
that what's up
so when is that their shoulders on like
the white like we'd all be like oh my
god you have you know so so
i guess for me it's just like
white people's embarrassment being the
reason they can't
like step up like you have to move
through that because you can't pretend
like it doesn't affect the way that you
behave and
and
act
because you're moving your shoulders
like what do you mean i don't see color
so
exactly then why are you dancing
exactly
in your body why are you saying albums
dropping with your shoulders
it's like and also thinking black people
are cool is not the same
as doing anti-racist work
at 1000 because that still
objectifies us knowing every lyric to
every tropical quest album doesn't make
you that's not
the same as like okay how do i make sure
that because you're still just
participating in the commodifying and
like you can appreciate but you're still
just participating in the capitalism of
like black car black culture et cetera
like that doesn't make you like being
able to acknowledge our dopeness doesn't
mean yeah
the anti-racism comes in being able to
acknowledge white supremacist trash that
like recognizing black dopeness is easy
it's never been a problem yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's never been from
it yeah i mean it's my my lawyer is
writing an entire book about how black
ip has just been systematically taken
over the years and years and years and
years and years that we've been in this
nation that's the easy part
the hard part is being able to
self-identify where have we gone wrong
as white people that's that's the part
you know and i feel like that's luckily
there
there is a
there's a movement in that right
direction i i mean george floyd sparked
an awakening of sorts and i think the
younger generation
does hold a lot of promise just in their
tenacity i mean that's always been the
case right like it's always been
the kids i mean the civil rights
movement was not led by
elders
you know it was propelled by youth who
were just like i'm done mom i'm about to
get arrested tonight because i'm gonna
go and sit at this woolworth
counter lunch counter but nonetheless
but like why aren't like is there like
who who
who can be like hey any movies
that
ben that are made about black trauma or
slavery all that money has to go that is
made any profits made from that have to
go to some kind of reparations fund like
how do you how but those are i mean
that's as easy as a chairman and ceo of
the
studio that makes the film like it's not
it's not i mean that can be
contractually designed like if i if if
steven spielberg decides to make
a bla a film that's chronicling i don't
know um like an that's chronicling adam
wells let's just say ida b wells
and he in the contract says that
on the back end of this
ten percent of this has to go to
this fund etc i mean that's how this
town
works and then has a lawyer that makes
sure
that it goes there and it's also it's
driven by the talent so it's like i did
this um
you know thing on community and sandra
bullock came on and uh mike jackson who
runs john legend's company he's like my
best friend from college and so i like
had him hop on and and we were talking
about
you know all the movies that he had in
development um
you know and
all the black people in the room that
were in the community room clubhouse i'm
sorry clubhouse not community clubhouse
um we're like we don't need to watch
those we're not going to those
like just make fun black stories like
we're good like we're good on that you
know and then um i learned something
that i would i don't know how i ever
would have gotten this information had i
not been in the pandemic and like on
clubhouse when everyone was just like
jumping in the rooms and people were
explaining to me that it's hard for
black uh people of color lgbtq people to
get into the unions because the union
hours is based on a model of 24 episodes
a year which does not happen anymore it
doesn't happen that ship has sailed six
eight episodes a year max so so when you
walk into a trailer and you're like how
come there's no black hair and makeup
artist for the black talent they're like
we can't get into the union so the very
unions that are supposed to protect
the people they're supposed to protect
they're now you also have to be you also
have to have referrals
crazy you have to have referrals and
line producers are not allowed to ask
are you black that's all are you lgbtq
are you asian nope so you're not allowed
to ask and then you're also not like and
then i mean i'm the one that got in
trouble
whatever time's up
didn't ask me back when i was like hey
why are all these famous actresses here
they don't hire anyone why aren't we
doing mixers for like line producers and
this was a phone call i didn't get
invited to any meetings um because they
know i'm the person that would be like
we're all wearing black to the golden
globes how about we don't go
right how about that no one wants to you
know and i'm like like a-list actresses
you seem lovely but like you show up
after everyone's already been hired like
you you can walk off the set if you get
someone smacks your ass like waitresses
can't like where's all this money going
where's all where where's the money and
we should do line producer um mixers
because those are the people that hire
and they're white guys that hire their
friends and it's illegal to ask someone
if they're black so it's like how
how's this gonna happen
but all of these things happen
by nature of having a hyper awareness
and applying it like i think there's a
scenario that you don't even remember
that
look at your face you're like it's
coming
there's a scenario i don't even think
you remember where we met the first time
we met
why did i black this out is this my you
wouldn't have known me
because i was auditioning for you the
lee daniels thing
because i think i almost
there was a moment where we almost just
wanted to hire you for that but i don't
know if it was it was a show for hbo
so
but that script
that was the first time i ever got a
call back and i got the call back
because i played the role very different
than it was described oh is this story
about me yes wow that's fucking wild i
just heard you tell this story this
story is about you this is
wild
wild this story is about you
and it was one of those times though
where i was man that was new
and i was like
is this this is really happening and we
went over email oh god no i never
communicated with you well i think you
communicated with a casting director
david yes because i was like
just randomly uh uh runs oscars now
hilarious i know so he affirmed me so
there was a
uh role that uh was in an hbo pilot that
i did and uh it was a character that i
was writing as a white woman who
didn't who was basing it on a
person that i saw on no person i know
and was written for her in a way and it
was like
yeah i was writing in a black woman's
voice and my brain just went
oh she's going to improvise on the day
like
these are placeholders and
there were lines in that script i still
remember to this day that's really
fucked
p is in parole
d is in death n is an n word that was a
line in a script that's wild
let me help you i was a heroin addict
and i think that in you and you're if
i'm just assuming yeah in you and your
co-writers minds it was like this is
funny
um
for a white woman it for a white woman i
don't know where that accent came from
but most please please
for a white woman that may have been
funny but that is why
the
the consciousness has to come from the
top of deciding who has to be a part of
a project for it to be done
properly for it to actually
be voiced properly yeah and that was a
time where it was like as a black
actress i was like this is very clearly
not written in my voice like this isn't
written by any by a black person yeah
but it is
if but it feels
wildly offensive yeah that someone would
think this is okay
to have a black person saying yeah and
they're only they can only think this
because they don't have the
consciousness to understand why a
monologue about a baby daddy yeah
it's not actually
uh
innovative and i went and i went through
this all again
with uh when i did a project with lee
daniels for amazon with tasha smith
ended up playing the part and it was
like
let's lee's only going to write the
black woman okay i'm only gonna like
because then and then i did something
with brandon goodman where it was like
okay
i i only write the white characters you
only write the black characters like and
we just broke off scenes because it was
like you know at the time
it was like
do you write a version of this
and then
uh the person i wrote it for comes in
and
just makes it their own and goes i would
never say this is crazy this is not who
i am whatever and it it
you know and i also
i kind of want to i kind of want to show
this too if we have time um stumbled
into a bunch of shit when i made jokes
about being uh from west virginia and i
made jokes on cordon about it and west
virginia came for me and they were like
you don't understand these aren't just
jokes you're we don't have clean water
and companies don't come here because
you're reinforcing the stereotype that
like does damage to people these aren't
just like making sure that your mansion
so sorry oh yeah you've got bigger
problems
but
i'm making a documentary about it
because um sort of where i grew up was
where john brown's raid was and um
that's where my dad like managed the
hotel and i and i and i just was like i
did damage it doesn't matter what my
intention was and like i think right now
we're at a point where it doesn't matter
if your heart was in the right place
like it doesn't matter your might but it
was my intention and whatever your
impact is if you did damage you did
damage and if you signed up to have a
platform and signed up to speak
and then you want to go like well what i
say shouldn't matter like
right because both can be true you can
both have had good intentions yeah and
make actions towards correcting any un
un uh unintentional harm and i think and
i think that
i'm sorry like that was stop apologizing
i i'm not white woman apologizing is one
of the most annoying shits ever i just
stopped i know but i'm sorry that you
have to like come on my podcast we have
to talk about like like some bullshit no
we have to talk about it because
we have platforms yeah and these are the
conversations that people are afraid to
have
and i have to talk about it because i
have to be a black woman who is
demonstrating to other black women like
nah it can get talked about for those
who are who those for because there's a
lot of black women who are like exactly
but then there's a lot of black women
who are like i don't feel like i can
say something you know and
it's like
there's
also a lot of white women who won't
create space for something to be said
and i think that like there was there
have been there were so many shows
before that where i was like you know
i'm just not going to write black
characters and then you get all right
you shouldn't totally and i think at the
time i i do you know why i can write
white characters because they all sound
the same and it's easy no because i
because that was my viewing experience
for so long
i mean monica is different than rachel
that's a different thing about wilson
phillips and that your best wife friend
wilson phillips you're dialed in that's
all you need to know but for so many
black folks like
we have always had to
adjust like but there's also been just
like such a plethora of white content
for us to consume that
by nature of just
quantity yeah yeah you know like i got
to see so many different white women
stories
like so many whereas like with black
women stories for a long time like
there's this kind of a cookie cutter
approach in the 90s we had this boom
yeah and it was beautiful incredible and
then that like got really truncated and
now
you get little seeds of stuff right you
know here and there but ultimately like
there hasn't
been the same
necessity for white people to have to
adjust and learn how to speak in these
different voices and spaces and exist in
duality that black people have had so i
have
had to learn how
people work if and by the way
so many black people feel like we've had
to learn
how
white personality how a white person's
personality operates in order to survive
or in order to get a job in order to
because and when i say that what i'm
talking about is you know you have to
access
okay they're existing from a place of
privilege they're coming from you know
like because white culture is just
privilege and oppression
yeah there's there's west virginia
culture there's southern culture there's
northeast culture there's wasp culture
but like white
as it exists that's not like a
like someone said someone said to me why
culture is golf
and i was like the only reason white
culture would be associated with golf is
because they were preventing black
people from playing golf yeah like the
only reason why only white people were
playing golf was because they wouldn't
let other people play golf which by the
way i'm still there's the jury is out
and no one can give me a straight answer
if golf actually the acronym stands for
gentlemen only ladies forbidden oh does
it it supposedly does oh wow i know so
that's something i'm still trying to
corroborate a lot of people say yes a
lot of people say no i've never heard
that before yeah isn't that wild um but
i'm only ladies
when poor people
like white people being broken into rich
white and poor white and i think poor
white is going like well we don't have
privilege it's like you know and this is
the moment where i have to go like yeah
you do man
because when you get pulled over you
don't get you you can walk down the
street and not get get murdered so you
don't even get indicted in the same way
your sentences are not the same way
like you're the scent like that's right
all of these things and for what it's
worth
the privilege that you're given
is the idea that you are better simply
because you're white and so that has
been a huge tool used by
the institution to keep white supremacy
alive using poor white folks yeah
and giving them this little carrot
dangle that says but at least you're
better than them you may have we may be
we may be giving you nothing yeah we
might be still building coal mines in
your neighborhood you might all still be
dying of all the same things that they
are because health care is available to
any of you but you're still better than
them because you're us you're us and
you're still going to live longer just
because you have less adrenaline and
cortisol on a daily basis from just the
stress of correct very basic things and
something that and i think for me this
gets me in trouble a lot like but my
brain i try to go to tend to go like
okay what are the big solutions like how
do we like like look at the things that
down the line are going to be fucked
which the conversation i feel like
that's not being
had right now is
the fact that robots are racist
and
that i mean truly like the robot
technology that that catches melanoma
depends on contrast between dark and
light skin so it essentially doesn't
apply to black people so even
even the
like
the automated sinks
like they don't turn on
yes like an automated sync that has like
the little sensor like a lot of
automated sinks like they don't turn on
for darker skin
it's not just motion it's it's also
light
i mean band-aids are racist i mean
band-aids are right band-aids crayons
are racist
you know and so um and also these you
know there's a big you know conversation
about going like okay the hiring process
is racist because you're gonna you know
obviously be biased but let's use robots
but because data is racist
if jerome and lisa
have the same credits right jerome is
going to have some fucked up algorithm
against him because data is racist based
on what the name jerome has yielded in
the past like there's a great article
i think it was in vox but so there's
also more things coming
that are terrifyingly inherently racist
that i just feel like i'm not seeing a
ton of conversation on when people say
like the robots are going to take over
the robots are going to kill us it's
like
also
[Music]
yeah
i mean
would that be so bad
you know like we're kind of dude
you know here's the thing
a lot of these conversations end up
being more about
a therapeutic venting than actual
solution finding yeah because
there's the problems are so excessive
the wickedness is so pervasive
that on some days i just don't
i don't even have like the here's what
we're gonna do you know i just have
the will
to consider
yeah that's it just like i have the will
to consider today that there might be
you know because in the same bubble
like we're still creating you know and
like trying to find
joy and trying to create spaces for joy
in the midst of like when you think
about the civil rights movement so many
of us really conceptualize it as
just this time of turmoil like that's
because it was a time of turmoil but
simultaneously during that time of
turmoil there was a lot of like
incredible
art made and joy made and you know i i
can't remember what interview i saw this
on but
it was a brother who had been mar who
marched during that era and it was an
elder and he was like
y'all think that we
just marched all the damn time he was
like we took breaks like we had to go
back to work we had to spend time with
our families like you have to re-up
yeah you have to re-up like you can't
just
stay on it because that's what they want
right now
i think
there is a panic that's still happening
about like
we're in a pandemic and
the awareness of things that we didn't
necessarily really really truly realize
like wow like they really they really
put all these people all these terrible
judges in all these supreme court
positions yeah and
it is bigger than we can conceptualize
and you know so there's a lot of like
wrapping our heads around
all of these things as we are in the
collapse but
what do you you know what my friend was
like i'm watching movies and shows about
folks who have either lived in fictional
or non-fictional times like this i just
watched munich on the edge of war and it
was an interesting film on netflix
because even though it is
historical fiction based on a novel it's
still an era of the nazi an era of world
war ii that i've never seen depicted on
screen and it's
pre
the war and they are in
germany
pre-the war and they're in germany and
it is so uncannily like america right
now
in terms of the sentiment the energy
the
um the rhetoric propaganda the
propaganda exactly the ability to i mean
the scapegoat is
just the ability to blame something
because you know terror management
theory has really helped me a lot
because you know
ernest becker's work i'm sure other
people have done um
further work on it because we're the
only species that kind of knows we're
gonna die
we are managing our terror and a lot of
times the way we default as a way to
feel like we have some kind of posterity
or value or um immortality is to go into
i know this word is problematic but like
tribal thinking us versus them to be
really into your trophies and your um
you know achievements and things that
will outlast you because you're
inevitably inevitably gonna perish a
spend terror management
really spikes uh and is exacerbated by
things like pandemic things like you
know um uh suicide clusters when you see
a bunch of suicide stuff in the news and
a bunch of deaths in the news people are
so afraid of their mortality that their
amygdala is going off so hard we're in
fight-or-flight mode and our frontal
lobe shuts down and it's just like us or
them like you're in this we're not at
war there's not the same scarcity
complex there used to be like there is
enough food to feed everyone in the
world right now right now but we still
think it's like it's you or me like like
oh self-preservation we've and we've
also like misnomered
selfishness as individualism
like
like we like to think of it as like you
know i'm just i'm i'm a person in the
world and i'm independent and it's like
you're selfish and there's a giant
absence of uh something that you talk
about a lot and very elegantly um on a
couple podcasts uh
um
uh
let me say what they were i mean you did
on the breakfast club the last last
appearance and hollywood unlocked but
we're not talking enough about ancestral
trauma epigenetic imprinting and
inherited uh guilt fear and shame which
is something that i have found
candace thompson was on last week and we
talked about girls
who's fully just smoking frogs
yeah you know what i mean like
she's just floating
through them in case like amanda i'm a
healer i just got like this i am because
i'm breastfeeding a mushroom at the
moment and i have gotten wisdom
i mean she's like on another level and
she has like infinite wisdom um but
being able to like
you saying like there's no way we can
move forward until we sort of like heal
our past and deal with the trauma and
figure out okay like what what's
hysterical what's historical how do we
not make permanent decisions based on
temporary feelings like how do we like
like heal all that pain so moving
forward we can be calm and not
reactionary you know and not
deal like inheriting you know
you know mice not that i'm a huge fan of
animal testing but
i've blathered about this before on the
podcast but it's really important to
remember that um when uh there was a
study where uh i think it was at um
what's the mit is that the place that
seems i'm sure was funded by epstein um
but
but still he got some good science
funded
i mean
you know you're gonna do something what
does your mom say the if you take the
money what is that you take their money
you take their shit
you take their money you gotta go to
epson island
but um uh but that uh mice when uh they
were electrocuted every time they
smelled a cherry blossom
uh their offspring every time they
smelled a cherry blossom they would
recoil and run to the end of the uh cage
like you can inherit fears people that
are incredibly afraid of heights
probably had an ancestor of the falafel
cliff people that are really afraid of
water people you know so it's so
recent well that's what like reiki is
all based on right releasing in your
body yeah and the
releasing of that energy and like the
way that your feelings manifest as
energy and they you know the body that
keeps the score and then just feeling
like you're at war all the time and
i think like living in new york yeah and
i think it's on like a totally that
fight or flight stuff but i think it's
you know your conversation about like
mental health and translating mental
wealth i think is um
like that's the thing right now because
it's like getting defensive and
operating out of like rage like well i
was trying to do the right thing like
it's it's impractical yeah and you're in
your
social
existence in your personal life you know
like i mean i didn't learn how to like
be able to be a partner to somebody
until i learned how to
not be not protect myself from them
and detached with love even within a
relationship going like that's not mine
that's old and
to me i've heard you talk a lot about
relationship stuff and it
has been it's so insightful but my
biggest thing has been like
say what you mean me what you say don't
say it mean and it's the one place in my
life where i'm like i can shut my whore
mouth right now and i
i can win this like i can
but you also there's a version of
winning but if i win we both lose well
that's what's gonna say i mean there's
there's what do they say in uh
um
of course on miracles you know a miracle
is a change in perspective so there's a
whole other version of winning if i win
us both winning that's us us both being
healthier after this conversation that's
also a win and
if i win that implies we're on different
teams already ooh there you go so we're
not so i'm already in a toxic place
there you go and
would i rather win this argument
or get back on tinder i mean and listen
there's a version of wind that's also
just the person being able to
acknowledge
what you're saying
which feels
like partnership right like
i'm saying this and it means something
to me and you being my partner are
acknowledging and affirming
that's a win and when you end like when
that's not happening it's like so i
guess i have to say this again yeah yeah
yeah i guess i have to say this i'm
going to keep saying it until you do
this and nev
and then it also is okay because the if
you have trauma right the traumatized
brain uh usually takes three days to be
able to for the um uh cortisol and the
adrenaline to like wear off from being
you know stressed so
even if i am gonna win this it can wait
three days
listen learning how to wait
has been my journey in life in
responding to texts
professional spaces like no emails
should be longer than two sentences you
know economy of words but also just like
preserving like that cortisol shit
you're talking about like that's really
not good for you right so like learning
how to
prevent that from having to be released
unnecessarily you know like just like
letting so many things anger you and so
often those
things are
not that deep
i can't i always say to all my cancer
friends i'm like cancers you can't get
cancer we need more cancers you listen
we age yourself
i mean i'm the empaths i the the empath
life is exhausting incredibly incredibly
exhausting it's exhausting for a number
of reasons like not just because you're
like feeling all the feelings all the
time but also because people who aren't
empaths like they can't
understand a lot of people can't
understand what that is and they misread
it yeah they miss they miss no more and
then
they're and now you're having to fight
against something else and the empath i
get you know like
who cares about the people who come for
me about it but it's like empath that's
like stop doing that
stop yeah
you're actually willing it i know i'm i
i to me i think it's
again like i say female comedians are
the most hated people on the planet and
i have
in i mean
the sh
from the get-go i was canceled you know
what i mean like when i dared have a tv
show i mean the the journalists the
white female journalists that came after
me listen white women eat each other
like rats in a cage yeah
y'all
and some of the people that have been i
mean the people that have been meanness
to me in this business by far have been
women
fine i'm happy to go like oh you guys
have the scarcity complex you had to be
you were the only woman in a male
dominant field you learned from the
mandate but also excuses excuses
yeah yeah but also that hurt my feelings
that was unnecessary you also made me
stronger so thank you because you made
me have to have a plan b and a plan c
and plan e and work twice as hard
i'm not thanking people
for
me having to be stronger because of
their fuck shit because that is the
black woman's well yeah i think it's a
white woman maybe it's it's i'm like you
know what nobody but i i'm i'm saying
this for everyone because maybe less
white women deserve spots anyway we do
that to make ourselves feel better about
the journey
we should not have to be stronger
because other people are weak right and
black
doctor i'm sorry black women have been
told by doctors that they have a lower
tolerance for pain
like i just
i don't
want to have to be stronger because
you're a fucking prick that's right yeah
yeah i don't need water
you know what i'm saying like i don't
want to have to thank
people
for their for me
using the alchemy of my
yeah
yeah compassion and my my heart to turn
their wickedness
into
like i don't want to have to be fucking
gandalf with these people
okay yeah i don't have to be spitting
gold out of your heart it needs to be
you shall not pass yeah yet
that's really what it is and mine is
definitely through my being in 12 step
programs the third step is just like
everything is a gift everything is a
gift like it's just it's how i learned
to survive okay and it was like that's
what you need comedians
comedians dick like i could take it like
it's just like okay you know
you're not gonna hire me fine
13th step yeah yeah is
giving this
the 13th step is actually when people uh
in the program abuse their power with
newcomers it's actually harassed them
but the 14 step um i'm not gonna uh uh
i'm just gonna try to have like faith
that at some point uh we'll be able to
have around two but there's like a
couple things i just wanna run by before
and if you need to just get up and leave
please do
um uh
i
just i brought this up with candace a
little bit and you mentioned your puppy
and just literally walk out or talk do
you leave right now i need to leave very
soon okay
is there anything you would like to i
need to know how to potty train this
damn dog okay so how old is the dog two
okay years yes oh okay did you recently
get or have had i've had but it was my
first dog
and i
thought i was doing what needs to happen
to potty train yeah
and it just
it's it
he's just not really you let me come to
your house for two hours yes
to potty training yes yes and here's the
problem i know you're not gonna like
this
but making this happen does involve a
fanny pack i love fanny packs okay then
we're good because it doesn't solve a
fanny pack and involves just not feeding
your dog at all out of a bowl you keep
your dog hungry only and you only feed
him when he pees outside okay only okay
and then anytime he does pee inside you
do have to throw something like a dog
ball at in his direction don't hit him
okay or use something called a pet
corrector which i'm going to give to you
to take with today you have to make it
the consequence really bad and you're
not going to want to and it's going to
suck and you're going to feel bad but it
doesn't matter so if he's being inside
it's just he's confused
he's he's just confused
because you because a lot of us go come
on man
like he doesn't know what that means
you know and
listen there's times i've had to tell
myself jordy is not doing this out of
spite it's all about cats and sometimes
i feel like it's like i got babbling
it's like it's it's it's just uh it's a
body language thing and it's also good
people don't you have to just make the
consequence terrible and then you can't
make eye contact with him for 30 minutes
oh so okay okay so it's really the the
thing that they that is the biggest
punishment for them is actually not the
negative reinforcement the hitting or
any yelling it's the no eye contact it's
i've lost my alpha
and i have been rejected from the pack
which even you have talked about humans
are animals and we are designed to get
the acceptance from the pack so if
because not having the acceptance of you
and the eye contact from you that means
certain death for pack animals so it
will take what kind of dog is it that's
a terrier chihuahua
actually i think you might be
i'm joking i'm joking i don't think it's
hard no it is it is it is it totally is
it's just about consistency for like
three days
huge negative reinforcement and it has
to happen within 30 seconds of
committing the crime or else they don't
understand why you're mad
okay so it's gonna take a little bit of
like if you have like three days where
you're just home yeah and like not
leaving or not
distracted just being there writing or
just so that you can get it right when
it happens
take him outside he then pees outside
fanny pack food because he's not getting
meals he's not getting just a bowl of
food okay he's got to stay hungry so as
soon as he poops outside not only is it
here's your food here's her food you
have to have like a party for him
it's like
and you'll pick him up and you're so
it's like then he's like i got it
because with them
a lot of people and it's not our fault
it's just
i'm not great with humans animals is the
only language i kind of know is really
like we tend to go oh what are you doing
i told you
but we're looking at them and they're
just it just looks like it just looks
like they're familiar
they're just like what's wrong with you
you know so got it it really is just
nice people
it it took me a lot of i had to
sometimes the owners usually need to be
trained that's
100 me and then by the way
it'll change your life when you're like
as amanda sales the person i see
sometimes going like why does she have
to spend any of her fucking bandwidth
acknowledging these people that are
giving her criticism who really aren't
they're just jealous of her or like her
or pulling her pigtails and then you'll
go like once you start doing that with
animals you're like oh i can just ignore
you
yes i don't have to go what are you
doing why are you coming for me i'm on
your side it's like no i just can ignore
bad behavior
yeah so i can ignore bad behavior yes
yeah i just i can totally ignore it
because that will make it dissipate
because the more i engage it they're
like well i just have to do bad behavior
and that's why i get man's attention
you know this is true this is facts i
mean it's the math is mathing or it's
like you know it's like it's it's
people on twitter like saying silly shit
it's the new like egging someone's house
i've had to let twitter go we've all had
we all did that when we were dumb i had
to let twitter go because i'm just like
i
y'all are y'all are very upset even if i
uh well it's i think we're gonna look
back in 50 years and i think there will
be laws around instagram and i think
people go that was self-righteous
indignation is a real addiction
when you go fuck you
you get adrenaline that turns into
dopamine it's the same thing as like
doing a drug or smoking or whatever and
i think we're gonna look back and go
well that was a bunch of like
addicts
getting their fix and we were conflating
that with actual mature feedback or
feedback we should actually
take into account
you know yeah but because twitter i
think is you tell me if i'm wrong one of
the first places that i think black
women actually have a voice and get to
sort of run shit it's hard to totally
discount
no i think all these social media spaces
have become a site of a black
renaissance and
of of speaking of performing of
um
creating of comedy you know it really is
just
um it is a
true testament to just like when the
space is free and open and clear how
prolific
uh
black people can be in this country and
um
and so you know we have to continue to
do that we you know just to see how
tick-tock went from just doing dances so
now there's like yeah there's
there's black education information yeah
so
yeah but i do have to go go okay and
because i did want to talk about um some
of your projects uh amanda steele is
difficult i'm very excited about this um
and uh you can subscribe to our patreon
smartphone
um and then uh can you flip through all
this stuff here because we'll do a
little outro before you go of all your
um some other stuff uh and then her
patreon we'll get into the other stuff
yeah
there's lots
[Music]
[Applause]